[Musique]
le cap des cent mille cas quotidiens
franchi en france noël une nouvelle fois
marquée par le cos vinh face à la
propagation du contagieux varions
omikron il a fallu s'adapter les tests
pris d'assaut emmanuel macron tiendra un
nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire
lundi
[Musique]
un noël sans lumière au liban empêtré
dans une crise aux multiples pays est
toujours privée de courant 80% de la
population vit aujourd'hui sous le seuil
de pauvreté le liban où l'anc est stable
16 mois après l'explosion qui a ravagé
capitale beyrouth
[Musique]
à l'arabie saoudite s'apprête à lancer
au yémen une opération militaire à
grande échelle réponse à la mort de deux
personnes dans le royaume saoudien une
attaque revendiquée par les rebelles
houthi la première en plus de trois ans
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
plus de tests réalisés et plus de 4 e
vide détecter les français se ruent dans
les labos ou encore les pharmacies
résultat plus de son 4000 nouveaux cas
de contamination ont été enregistrés ce
samedi la barre des 50 mille avait été
passé le 4 décembre ce chiffre a donc
doublé en trois semaines selon les
données de l'agencé sanitaire et c'est
ainsi un nouveau record depuis le début
de l'épidémie à l'heure des
retrouvailles en famille sébastien bach
comme chaque année l'église de saint
germain l'auxerrois de paris accueille
des dizaines de fidèles entre ses murs
pour célébrer la naissance du christ
mais ce vendredi soir en lieu et place
de l'eau bénite c'est du gel
hydroalcoolique qu'ont trouvé les
visiteurs
toute personne qui vient qui rentre
d'abord doit porter le masque doit
ensuite est à voir du gel ensuite on sûr
qu'ils vont s'asseoir et pour la
communion ils communient dans la main il
n'y a pas de baiser paix notre seule
donne la paix comme cela il n'y a donc
aucun contact même les chanteurs les
enfants qui vont chanter chante avec un
masque pour être suez sont bien écarté
pour être sûr de ne pas
transmettre mais sont tous testés
négatifs on est cinq donc on sera 5
demain aussi voilà on est en petit
comité il n'est pas question de se
retrouver avec des amis
voilà avec les gens beaucoup de gens de
l'extérieur je sais que le colis des
prisons après j'avoue que j'ai vite dont
peu d'y penser toute la journée h 24
parce que sinon je pense que ce serait
beaucoup trop stressant des festivités
de fin d'année sous la menace de mikron
alors pour passer les fêtes en famille
les français se sont fait tester en
masse ce vendredi le pays a enregistré
plus d'un million de tests pcr et
antigénique un record depuis le début de
la pandémie malheureusement accompagné
d'un autre chiffre plus de 94 milles
contamination ont été enregistrés en 24
heures en france un cadeau de dernière
minute dont les professionnels de santé
se serait bien passé dans les hôpitaux
la vague omicron fait envisager le pire
actuellement nous avons
douzy de réanimation ouvert et quatre
lits du vc unité de surveillance
continue nous avons dû fermer pour
prendre des personnels
deux lits de surveillance continue
pendant cette période de noël nous avons
à l'heure actuelle
cette passion qu vide qu'ils sont
tous sont vaccinés et qui sont des
copies qui sont graves dont des traces
que dans les sept patients il y en a six
qui sont intubés ventilé face à un
risque réel de paralysie du pays le
gouvernement a convoqué un conseil de
défense sanitaire lundi prochain suivie
d'un conseil des ministres il y sera
notamment question des règles
d'isolement et de surveillance
possiblement adapté aux variants omicron
[Musique]
et la pandémie a bouleversé nos
relations difficiles en particulier en
cette période de fêtes l'analyse de
notre éditorialiste sociologue michel
fize
je crois que c'est une tendance lourde
un de nos sociétés d'un autre en
particulier un que que de voir se
réduire et même disparaître les contacts
humains nous connaissons tous les
supermarchés sans caissière
les stations-service en pompiste il ya
déjà très longtemps les agence bancaire
ou postal sans agent et puis on a même
inventé les cartes bancaires sans
contact
alors c'est assez extraordinaire c'est
que le mot contacts etc en quelque sorte
devenu tabou 1 kg at-il de pire
aujourd'hui en période de pandémie
qu'être un cas contacts alors qu'en fin
de compte contact c'est le propre des
sociétés un ca ça veut dire le lien
entre entre les gens alors le virus lui
il a une autre stratégie 1 il a
d'ailleurs ses porte parole politique
maintenant et on nous répète à longueur
de temps ne vous y trompez pas ne vous
réunissez pas ne vous touchez pas donc
tout ceci nous nous éloigne évidemment
de ce qu'est une société qui est encore
une fois le rapprochement entre les gens
et les contaminations variant mikron son
vol sur le vieux continent confinement
couvre-feu fermeture des frontières
dépistage massif plusieurs pays renouer
avec un certain nombre de restrictions
tant de raisons avec quentin voeckler
des files d'attentes à n'en plus finir
que ce soit dans la rue ou dans leur
voiture les italiens se sont massivement
ruée vers les centres de dépistage ce
vendredi veille de noël un test négatif
pour passer un réveillon plus serein
pour autant dans les rues un autre sujet
était au coeur des discussions celui du
retour du masque obligatoire en
extérieur une mesure qui ne connaît pas
encore sa date d'entrée en vigueur mais
qui ne convainc pas déjà l'ensemble des
italiens
j'y suis favorable parce que c'est
peut-être une façon de sortir de cette
situation
espérant que c'est comme un souhait de
bonnes vacances pour tout le monde
nous sommes encore revenue en arrière à
ce stade nous devons faire un autre
effort et porter le masque
mais ce n'est pas une chose qui
m'enthousiasme
je ne suis pas habitué à cela de mon
point de vue l'obligation du masque en
plein air est un nom
le masque obligatoire en extérieur une
restriction également en place en grèce
le gouvernement demande de porter un
masque ffp2 dans les transports et les
supermarchés ou de positionner deux
masques chirurgicaux en cas de non
possession d'un masque ffp2
je dirais que les mesures sont
insuffisantes
elle aurait dû être plus stricts
une fois nous sommes libres une fois
nous sommes enfermés nous ne faisons que
suivre les ordres
en espagne également le masque est re
devenu obligatoire en extérieur depuis
jeudi sur l'ensemble du territoire dans
la deuxième ville du pays à barcelone le
port du masque obligatoire dans les rues
est accompagnée d'autres restrictions un
couvre-feu entre 1h et 6h une réduction
de 50% de la capacité d'accueil pour les
restaurants cela m'affecte à 100% parce
que nous ne pouvons pas avoir deux
terrasses parce que j'ai un kiosque et
une rampe pour handicapés devant donc
ils ne l'acceptent pas et avoir les 50%
à l'intérieur m'affecte au maximum c'est
une malchance surtout au moment où on
est dans une période où on a beaucoup de
travail dans les environnements fermés
certaines restrictions sont ok mais dans
les restaurants ou iata ses distances je
pense que c'est injuste surtout pour le
secteur de la restauration qui a
vraiment des moments difficiles je pense
que la distance est respecté il n'y a
pas de place pour ces restrictions des
restrictions contesté par une partie des
populations mais si le pic épidémique
n'est pas encore atteint les chiffres de
la contamination bat les records à
l'instar de la france le royaume uni a
enregistré plus de 122 mille cas c'est
d'amener à 24 heures plus de cent mille
pour le deuxième jour consécutif la
vague ou mikron est un véritable
raz-de-marée en europe est devenu un
outil incontournable pour réduire les
risques de contamination le masque
chirurgical pourrait se révéler néfaste
pour l'environnement en cause son faible
taux de recyclage et sa lente
décomposition les explications en images
[Musique]
le polypropylène n'est pas biodégradable
dans la nature ni compostables il va se
dégrader par l'action des uv l'oxydation
dans un processus qui peut prendre des
dizaines voire des centaines d'années
mais sans qu'au final ils ne soient
biodégrader
[Musique]
et le liban lui célèbre son troisième
noël en pleine crise elle a débuté à
l'automne 2010 neuf créé aujourd'hui
économique financière politique
économique sociale et à cela s'ajoute
l'enlisement de l'enquète concernant
l'explosion au port de beyrouth il ya
plus d'un an
la population est de plus en plus
méfiante à l'égard des autorités farah
mais qui
cette année
le liban fait un sombre noël à beyrouth
les décorations sont limitées et la
plupart des rues sont vides la crise
économique qui fait rage dans le pays
entraînent de graves pénuries d'énergie
résultat le liban est privée de courant
électrique mais aussi de nombreux
services un quotidien épuisant pour la
population il n'y a pas du tout
d'ambiance festive cette année
normalement pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année nous avons beaucoup de travail
d'habitude c'est très bon pour le
business mais aujourd'hui je n'ai qu'une
ou deux commandes ce n'est vraiment pas
bon pour mes affaires ou pour ma famille
la situation est vraiment difficile à
vivre
cette année comme vous pouvez le voir il
n'y a pas de décorations de noël ou de
lumière à cause de la crise économique
il n'y a pas d'électricité et la
municipalité ne veut pas dépenser
d'énergie pour les routes l'ambiance est
vraiment très différente cette année ce
n'est pas une ambiance joyeuse tout le
monde essaye de gagner sa vie et d'avoir
un peu de nourriture c'est tout ce que
nous pouvons faire
depuis 2019 les autorités libanaises
connaissent une lourde crise politique
interne qui ébranle le bon
fonctionnement économique du pays la
monnaie nationale s'est effondré jusqu'à
perdre plus de 95% de sa valeur un
contexte instable que le gouvernement
libanais peine à redresser la veille de
noël le premier ministre s'est voulu
optimiste quant à l'action du
gouvernement
nous sommes déterminés à surmonter tous
les obstacles pour réunir à nouveau le
gouvernement et poursuivre les efforts
que nous avons commencé à déployer pour
remettre le liban sur la voie du
redressement et du sauvetage cette
semaine antonio guterres s était en
déplacement dans le pays du cèdre le
secrétaire général de l'onu a appelé les
autorités à trouver des solutions pour
mettre fin aux souffrances du peuple et
pour établir la vérité sur l'explosion
du port de beyrouth
j'ai exhorté les dirigeants politiques
du liban à mettre en oeuvre des réformes
qui répondent monde du peuple libanais
pour plus de bien-être de responsabilité
de protection et de transparence afin de
restaurer l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
survenu en août 2020 cette
impressionnante explosion avait fait
plus de deux cent quinze morts et 6000
500 blessés mais depuis l'enquêté
s'enlise la classe dirigeante politique
est pointé du doigt accusés d'entravés
l'enquète à coups de nombreux recours
déposés chez le juge une affaire qui
paralyse le gouvernement mais également
l'ensemble des libanais d'après les
nations unies près des trois quarts de
la population vivant en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté au liban
plus d'une semaine après le passage de
la tempête qui a ravagé l'archipel des
philippines les survivants tentent de
reprendre le cours d'une vie normale
tant bien que mal face à la perte de
leurs biens et à la pénurie alimentaire
le typhon rail a fait près de 400 morts
et des centaines de milliers de sans
abri le récit de yamina benguigui
c'est un noël sous les décombres pour
ces philippins frappé le 16 décembre par
le typhon rei dont les vents aller
jusqu'à 195 km heure aujourd'hui les
victimes tentent de survivre
voilà nous n'avons rien à manger
si des gens généreux nous donne quelque
chose nous seront reconnaissants
c'est difficile
ou pas
c'est difficile parce que nous n'avons
rien à manger on doit mendier
c'est la plus forte tempête a frappé
l'archipel cette année au moins 375
personnes ont perdu la vie dans le sud
et dans le centre des philippines
agriculteurs et pêcheurs ont également
vu leurs moyens de subsistance détruits
et des milliers de familles se sont
retrouvées sans abri
l'onu a lancé ce vendredi un plan
humanitaire évalué à 106,5 millions de
dollars malgré tout certains s'estiment
heureux d'être en vie à la période
de noël sera triste
nous n'avons pas de nourriture de noël
mais au moins on est en vie c'est mieux
que de devoir fêter noël avec la perte
d'un proche on remercie dieu que notre
famille et notre communauté est est
épargné
un coup dur pour cette destination
touristique
déjà à la peine après dix-huit mois de
restrictions liées à la crise sanitaire
et avec l'arrivée du virus omicron les
espoirs d'un retour à la normale sont
revus à la baisse
le président philippin a retardé
l'ouverture des frontières prévu le 1er
décembre et qu'une nouvelle vague
épidémique met à mal les finances du
pays natal
j'ai peur que cela puisse être aussi
graves que les souches de virus
précédente je suis en quelque sorte
nerveux parce que laissez moi être franc
avec le public les finances des
philippines ont vraiment été épuisés les
italiens ont
[Musique]
plus de 43 union des 110 millions
d'habitants ont été vaccinées jusqu'à
présent dans le pays le gouvernement
veut axer sa politique sur une
intensification de la campagne vaccinale
le ministère de la santé à manille a
signalé plus de 2,8 millions de cas de
kovy de 19 et 50 1916 décès aux
philippines soit le deuxième total le
plus élevé en asie du sud est après
l'indonésie
une nouvelle journée de violence au
soudan font deux mois jour pour jour
après le coup d'état militaire des
dizaines de mille manifestants se sont
rassemblés pour protester à khartoum la
capitale et dans plusieurs autres villes
du pays des grenades lacrymogènes ont
été tirés pour voir pousser certains
manifestants qu'ils s'approchaient du
palais présidentiel les autorités ont de
nouveau coupé le réseau internet les
communications téléphoniques depuis le
putsch du 25 octobre dernier 48
manifestants ont été tués
l arabie saoudite se lancent une
opération militaire à grande échelle au
yémen riposte à la mort de deux
personnes l ont été tués lors d'une
attaque revendiquée par les rebelles
houthistes dont le royaume saoudien à
ryad
à la tête depuis 2015 d'une coédition
pour appuyer les forces gouvernementales
yéménites
les derniers éléments avec media swiffy
une attaque mortelle mené sur le
territoire saoudien par les outils cela
n'était plus arrivé depuis près de trois
ans
vendredi soir deux personnes ont été
tuées lors d'une offensive dans une
région près de la frontière avec le
yémen un acte rapidement revendiquée par
les rebelles chiites un projectile est
tombé sur un bâtiment commercial faisant
deux morts un saoudien et un résident
yéménite il a blessé sept civils dont
six saoudiens et un résident bengladais
une attaque qui a poussé le royaume a
lancé une nouvelle opération militaire à
grande échelle elle prévoit notamment un
appui à la coalition militaire qu'il
dirige et qui soutient le gouvernement
yéménite face aux rebelles une décision
qui pourrait aboutir à une
intensification des bombardements
aériens sur sanaa où trois civils sont
morts ce samedi la capitale sous blocus
saoudien depuis 2016 n'est plus en
mesure d'accueillir les avions de
l'organisation humanitaire et des
nations unies en représailles à cette
intervention d'envergure les rebelles
promettent une réponse douloureuse à
ryad
nous promettons régime saoudien d
opération douloureuse tant qu'il
poursuivra son agression et ses crimes
à sanaa la situation semble être
dramatique avec l'une des crises
humanitaires les plus importantes de la
planète
une situation qui pourrait encore
s'aggraver alors que 80% de la
population yéménite dépend des aides
internationales
d'après l'onu le conflit au yémen aura
provoqué la mort de trois cent soixante
dix sept mille personnes d'ici la fin
d'année 2021
allard si challans la fin des manoeuvres
militaires dans le sud du pays et près
de l'ukraine reds avaient lieu depuis un
mois sur plusieurs terrains à l'origine
de tensions entre kiev et moscou le
ministère russe de la défense indique
que plus de dix mille militaires sont
rentrées dans leurs bases la
correspondance de vera goff man
10 mille militaires russes rentrer dans
leurs bases après des exercices qui ont
duré en moi les entraînements se sont
déroulés dans le sud de la russie au
sein de la région d'astrakhan volgograd
rostov krasnodar ainsi que dans des
républiques du caucase du nord est en
crimée certaines de ces régions se
trouvent à la frontière russo
ukrainienne source de tensions ces
dernières semaines entre la russie et
plusieurs pays occidentaux
ces derniers accusant moscou de préparer
une attaque contre l'ukraine les
militaires russes quant à eux affirment
que malgré la fin des exercices ils
restent vigilants quant à d'éventuelles
situations d'urgence écouter
afin de maintenir un haut niveau de
préparation au combat dans toutes les
formations unités du district militaire
sud des unités de service des renforts
et des forces pour faire face aux
conséquences d'éventuelles d'urgence
seront déployés pendant la période des
vacances du nouvel an de plus les unités
de défense aérienne des équipages de
certains navires de la flotte de la mer
noire et de la flottille caspienne les
unités de guerre électronique et les
équipes de service des véhicules aériens
tactiques de l'armée et sans pilotes
seront déployés pendant les dix premiers
jours de janvier la russie souhaite
néanmoins obtenir dès que possible une
réponse des états unis et de l'otan à
propos de leurs demandes de garanties de
sécurité mutuelle mais il n'y a pas de
date limite a déclaré ce matin le porte
parole du kremlin dmitri peskov la
diplomatie russe a initié ces derniers
jours ce projet qui pourrait déboucher
sur un dialogue avec washington
prochainement moscou a présenté le 12
décembre des propositions et a demandé
l'engagement des états unis pour bloquer
le déploiement de l'otan vers l'est
notamment dans des pays comme l'ukraine
parmi les autres demandes du kremlin
obtenir la certitude que l'alliance
atlantique ne construisent pas à la nir
des bases militaires dans des états de
l'ex-bloc soviétique
et le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images la
commission vérité-réconciliation
recommande des poursuites judiciaires
contre l'ex-chef d'état yahya jammeh
devant un tribunal international son
rapport vient d'être rendu public il
avait été remis en novembre dernier au
nouveau président de la gambie adama
barro et à jamais rester au pouvoir
pendant un an deux ans accusée par la
commission notamment de meurtres
détentions arbitraires des disparitions
la recherche de survivants s'est
poursuivie ce samedi en mer egée au
lendemain d'un nouveau naufrage de
migrants une embarcation transportant
plus de 80 personnes a chaviré hier ss
d'entre elles ont perdu la vie 63 autres
ont pu être secourus et conduite vers la
grèce depuis mercredi c'est le troisième
naufrage lors d'une traversée entre la
turquie et la grèce ce qui porte le
bilan de ces drames à répétition à au
moins 30 morts cette semaine
des pluies les inondations meurtrières
en bolivie au moins douze personnes ont
perdu la vie sept des neuf régions du
pays ont été placées en état d' alerte
près de 1700 foyers et plus de mille
hectares de terrain sont touchés par des
crues la saison des pluies a débuté fin
novembre
elle devrait se poursuivre jusqu'au mois
de mars
un retour en france où l'association
droit au logement fera appeler un
rassemblement devant le ministère du
logement à paris une mobilisation pour
interpeller la ministre sur les
conditions de vie des personnes sans
domicile fixe notre reporter est el farj
étaient sur place
faire du bruit le jour de noël c'est
l'objectif de ce rassemblement organisé
par l'association dal droit au logement
ce qu'il réclame et bien c'est tout
simplement l'application des lois ce
sont leurs mots par exemple
l'application de la loi dalo elle permet
aux personnes mal logées d'être reconnus
prioritaires pour faire valoir leur
droit à un logement est digne autre
revendication la réquisition est des
logements vides ou encore le financement
de la construction de la construction de
logements sociaux je propose d'écouter
jean baptiste eyraud on vient dire
aujourd'hui à abadan wargon la ministre
du logement il faut qu'elle s'occupe
d'eux fera qu elle fasse appliquer les
lois et les droits des mal-logés des
sans logis des locataires à commencer
par la loi de réquisition on a 3 2
millions de logements vacants dans notre
pays mais aussi produire massivement du
logement social alors que on a de moins
en moins de logements sociaux et
appliquer la loi dalo le droit au
logement opposable qui normalement quand
une personne est reconnue prioritaire
doit être relogé dans un délai de six
mois on a aussi le droit à l'hébergement
pour toutes les personnes sont sans abri
devraient être hébergés peut pas les
laisser dans le froid alors qu'on a
c'est 3,2 millions de logements vacants
donc pour nous pour nous il est clair
que il est clair qu'il doit y avoir une
application de la loi claire ferme et ce
que ne fait pas ce que je refuse de
faire le gouvernement voilà pour les
revendications selon le dal plus de
trois millions de logements seraient
vacants dans toute la france est en
pleine période de fêtes les sages femmes
sont appelés par des syndicats une
semaine noire elle réclame notamment
plus d'effectifs une revalorisation
salariale et meilleure reconnaissance de
leur profession
l'augmentation de 500 euros au foie a
annoncé par le ministre de la santé ne
leur convient pas elle la juge
insuffisante et céline ricker délégué
syndical la cftc raconte son quotidien
souvent difficile
j'étais en garde jeudi la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi là
on a fait cet accouchement plus les
consultations être sage femme donc on
avait nos six femmes on n'a que cinq
salles d'accouchement plus la salle
nature donc six salles avec des
patientes un travail pour trois
sages-femmes en gérant en même temps les
consultations avec deux patientes ont
quand même c'est nier plus d'un litre un
des nouveaux nés pour lesquelles on a dû
appeler les pédiatres
on ne s'est pas posé une seconde
c'est à dire même pas le temps de
prendre un cachet
de feu d'aller aux toilettes simplement
voilà le buteur quand la relève et est
arrivé quand on a pu passer le relais et
dont on a mangé notre pas de la nuit
parce que parce qu'on n'en pouvait plus
il ne fallait reprendre des forces avant
de pouvoir rentrer chez eux
la patiente qui a accouché en sa nature
aurait aimé bénéficier d'une péridurale
mais nos salles étaient pleines ce
n'était pas possible et on termine ce
journal avec ces images du télescope
spatial james webb qu'il a été lancée
sans accroc par la fusée ariane 5 depuis
la base de kourou en guyane 27 minutes
après le lancement le télescope s'est
séparé de son lanceur il lui faudra
encore un mois pour atteindre sa
position finale à un million cinq cent
mille kilomètres de la terre
l'exploration scientifique ne devrait
pas débuter avant six mois
avec ça la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi ce prochain point sur
l'actu dans une trentaine de minutes à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles pas les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement ils sont coupés de tout
il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé avec
un téléphone et il peut me donner des
nouvelles non à votre avis quelles sont
ses conditions de détention aujourd'hui
c'est sûr elles sont très difficiles
parce que les anciens otages ont pu nous
le racontait qu'il a des conditions de
vie qui sont très rudimentaires et très
dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon coeur
qui qui reçoit notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux tout
simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent parce
que c'est ça mon travail c'est la france
et le mali où la france ou le mali qui
vont libérer olivier g pas ce pouvoir de
libérer mais par contre j'ai le devoir
de mobilisation je ne l'abandonnerai
part je ne laisserai pas
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
alexandre roubtzoff est un enfant de
saint pétersbourg au club
l'immense capitale de la russie
impériale en avril 1914 il débarque à la
roulette je n'avais imaginé dans les
brumes et le raffinement glacée de ma
ville natale que je trouverai ici tant
de grâce deux simples élégance et de
poésie dans des lieux et parmi des êtres
non je ne savais à peu près rien
aux offres pendant plus de trente ans il
à peindre des paysages de tunisie parce
qu'il était tombé amoureux de ce pays de
cette ligne n'avait absolument pas de
voyeurisme dans le temps le regard de
roxas mais une une empathie totale
ce sont eux les bédouins montagnards ou
du désert qui sont beaux noble et
raffinée tandis que nous autres nous
sommes mesquin et inélégant si ce
n'était pas tant à l'intérieur du pays
dans l'âme du pénis et c'est là qu'il
veut transmettre
alexandre roubtzoff aura pas jusqu'aux
derniers jours de sa vie les sentes
inachevé le tableau de la mosquée de
sidi mehrez vénéré entre toutes au
centre de tunis ultime geste d'amour
pour le seul pays qui aura vraiment
compté pour lui
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches je
vais vous faire part d'un secret le
royaume uni n'a pas disparu contre toute
attente
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ses
cages cela fera un an le 31 décembre
2021 que le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne
alors un an après le divorce comment se
porte l'économie britannique on va
tâcher de vous éclairer dans cette
émission avec vous olivier bonjour
bonjour russell et puis nous sommes
aussi avec pierre à bentata maître de
conférences à l'université aix-marseille
bonjour et brûlerie dans ces caches on
va commencer à part un état des lieux de
l'économie de la grande-bretagne c'est
avec le tiroir-caisse d'antonne gaza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an après difficile de faire un
diagnostic économique du départ des
anglais de lui car la pandémie fausse
quelque peu le résultat sur son sol
après une récession énorme en 2020 de
près de 10% la plus forte des pays du g7
en 2021 la grande bretagne a vu arriver
le rebond économique au deuxième
trimestre la croissance était de 5,5
pour cent au troisième elle a fortement
ralenti pour atteindre 1,3 pour cent
cela s'expliquerait en partie par une
difficultés rencontrées tout au long de
l'année les pénuries surtout de
personnel en particulier de chauffeurs
routiers
selon la fédération des transporteurs le
pays manque actuellement de 100 1000
conducteurs ceux qui causent donc des
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour des
produits alimentaires ou pour le
carburant et ralentissent la reprise
d'activité
les pénuries de main d'oeuvre ont
également touché bon nombre d'autres
métiers et atteint des records dès la
moitié de 2021 avec près d'un million de
postes vacants la faute à la fois où cos
vide et au brésil qui aurait poussé bon
nombre de travailleurs et rang